hello everyone and welcome to a truly
awesome game from the first round of the
uh tepe sigmund tournament that is
currently being played in malmo sweden
uh it's arjun irrigation or could be a
gracie the couple of uh videos that i've
made i pronounced that as eric then i've
received some emails that it's actually
pronounced erika ishii so uh sorry about
that i will uh try to pronounce it
properly now uh but if it's not if it's
actually ac then again uh send me a
couple of emails and we will figure it
out um he's been playing some incredible
chess he is uh getting very very close
to that 2700 rating i think he's down
some 25 points uh but um you know it's a
those last 25 points is like is like a
huge amount mountain to climb uh and
here his opponent in the first round is
uh well are very well known uh alexei
shiro uh none other than the master of
the mystic hearts uh you know that is
going to be an attacking game now the
only question is how attacking is it
going to be and who will be on the
receiving end of uh fully attacking uh
so let's dive straight into it it's um
uh
there is quite a lot to enjoy uh so
arjun with the white pieces opens with
d4 sorry about that
uh we have d5 by shear of uh c4 and now
c6 we have knight to f3 knight to f6 and
now knight to c3 we have e6 and bishop
to g5
d captures on c4 and now going for the
uh incredibly sharp botwinning variation
of the uh
of the semi-slav so e4 now preparing e5
we have b5 inviting e5 and this has all
been played many many times so it's not
a problem e5 not challenging the knight
and h6 now so we don't lose a piece
bishop h4 and now g5 challenging the
bishop here knight captures and g5h
captures bishop captures we're going to
win our piece back with e captures on f6
knight beat to d7 and now e captures on
f6 you don't have to play this right
away there are many other attempts here
that are popular such as g3 bishop to e2
but e captures then f6 is the most
popular idea
bishop to b7 and now comes bishop to e2
again here the most popular is g3
but this kind of runs into a forced line
because now you allow c5 to come with
tempo then you have to play d5 the
position is now very well known and uh
most likely both of them know this so
here uh
arjun wants the surprise hero with a
bishop to e2 now he's preparing bishop
to f3 so then c5 will no longer be an
option
and now we have knight captures on f6
here uh queen to b6 and also queen to a5
are the most popular options uh shiro
goes for knight captures on f6 so now uh
he will uh either have to keep his queen
on the 8 or he will have to play bishop
e7 in order to activate the queen so now
bishop to f3
bishop to e7 and now there are a couple
of moves that have been played in
possession like queen e2 also h4 is a
known move but here we have g3 now and
it is as of move 14 that we have a
completely new game
uh so now g4 is much much stronger than
it was in that position because c5 is no
longer an option that the bishop on b7
would just hang
so here we have queen to b6 and this is
now uh the first true uh truly uh
sheet of move uh because if you play
knight to d5 which is pretty much what
uh everyone would play it's uh it's it's
pretty much we trade everything down and
we we call it a day but okay maybe not
really for example bishop captures queen
captures the knight is a monster on d5
now uh let's say white castle's king
side we're going to castle queen side
and it still could be a very very
aggressive game castles on opposite
sides of the board where black gets to
exploit the semi-open h file but white
also gets the uh play a4 so it's gonna
be it it's gonna be a race but this is
definitely something uh that black
should play however shiro doesn't even
wanna waste time on knight study d5 he
starts with queen to b6 he wants the
castle and go after that d for pawn uh
thinking that it will probably cost
arjun a tempo uh to defend this d4 pawn
but here we have castles castles uh and
now queen to e2 just getting the queen
out of the way sacrificing the d4 pawn
and this is probably something that came
to alexa as a surprise as uh well uh
it's not not a pleasant thing to
have to do to capture a pawn especially
if you're such a natural born attacker
like should have you prefer to be
attacking and always having that
initiative rather than picking up upon
and allowing your opponent to consult it
or even to start the attack but okay
here you kind of have to do it queen
captures on d4 was played now rook after
d1 attacking the queen queen to c5
putting pressure on the bishop here and
now pawn to h4 just defending the bishop
rook h the g8 and now uh now we have
rook captures on the eighth bishop
captures on the e8 and the bishop
captures on f6
uh bishop captures an f6 and not knight
to e4 this will now force a trade of
knight for bishop so yeah black will no
longer have the bishop pair queen to e5
as the queen was also attacked knight
captures an f6 and okay you could play
queen captures on e2 but then after the
trade you're just going to be down
material so queen captures on f6 and
then now comes h5 so this is the
position that um
i think shiro did not have in mind when
he decided to go for that queen to b6
idea instead of the knight to d5 one as
now there is really no good way to
activate the bishop on b7 and well we
have a protected passport on on h5 so
that will be an issue in the long run so
here rook to d8 here should have again
has to has to create some active chances
he wants to play c3 and try to win that
um d2 square
for the rook or if c3b captures queen
captures then the queen will also be
controlling the d2 square
so the rook can uh go to this very
active d2 square but arjun says not a
problem i'm just going to play a4
c3
uh and now a captures on b5 and here uh
shiro makes a slight inaccuracy he plays
c captures on b2 uh but much much
stronger was a rook to d2 and now it
seems weird because you're not going to
be able to ca to play c captures on b2
but that's exactly what you're going to
play after the white queen moves after
queen to e3 now we capture and now okay
the rook is not hanging because we're
threatening to pick this rook up with
check and only after rook to b1 now we
move the rook to c2 and now we have
immense pressure here against against
the white king so this is uh what shiro
uh
should have played he he played captures
on b2 right away but now now it's a bit
different rook to b1 and now of course
you you have no way of playing rook to
d2 and that's uh that's a big problem so
now c5 uh but uh
bishop to c6 saying that okay if you
want to capture then you allow something
like queen to a6 could be a very
problematic
position for black and here uh shiro
says all right now i'm going to play a5
and now if you capture alpha sonden
nothing is defending your bishop here
however best for black was again c4 and
it's again a very very tricky idea uh
point is you are inviting queen captures
on c4 just to get this rook to d2 and
then you have no more worries in the
world because black has too much
pressure uh in order for whites to try
and do anything and even if bishop
captures king captures queen c6 check
after king to b8 there's really nothing
for
uh for white to do here uh you're gonna
have to settle for a draw queen eight
check queen c6 check we need to check so
uh c4 was kind of what you had to do but
shiro always goes for that most exciting
idea that uh leaves the chances on the
board so he plays a5 now he wants to
play a for a three a two uh now comes
rook captures on b2 uh a4 we have rook
to d2 now offering a rook trade and now
a3
but it is not enough uh
here okay you could go for rook captures
and the eight queen captures on the
eight and h6 it's definitely the way to
go
but here we have rook to a2 arjun gives
a little bit of a chance to share with
the bonds back
so queen to c3 now defending the pawn
and now comes h6 we have rook to h8
preparing to pick up this spawn now
comes queen to d1 threatening queen d7
check and queen captures and b7 with
checkmate so here we kind of have to
trade bishop captures we have pawn
captures again the same checkmate is um
uh glooming over the over the position
uh and now queen to d4 uh offering a
queen trade you cannot allow this and um
the problem for for sure is that he
can't really prevent the white queen
from infiltrating so queen to b3 now
again queen to b7 is coming queen to b4
and now we have queen to d3 again with
the same threat but now queen to d7 and
queen the a6 are being threatened and
there's just no good way to go about
this so here we have rook to d8 you have
to allow something queen to asexual king
c7
uh and now rook captures on a3 eliminate
all of black's chances and now if black
does not have a perpetual uh it's just
going to be an easy win so here queen b1
check king g2 rook to d1 was played uh
seems like white king should also be in
trouble now but queen to a7 checked
and now you see the problem if you
capture the pawn uh which was played in
the game i'm gonna tell you what happens
here or rather if you know uh the pawn
was the pawn was captured but if you
play king to d6 uh trying to avoid um
capturing because you know you could
maybe hide behind the pawn sometimes
this is possible uh then there's queen
d7 cher king e5 rook to e3 check king to
f6 and now rook f3 check now this is
hanging so you kind of have to go back
and then after queen captures on f7
there's just nothing for for black to do
here once you try a few checks king h3
rook h1 check king g4 the king is
perfectly safe here and even after queen
e4 uh you don't even have to block you
can play king g5 and the black has no
more useful moves you're just going to
play c even c7 c8 and that's just it
uh so very very interesting stuff so i
should have had the capture on c6 uh
that's the only attempt left but now
queen to a8 check and this is a a
crucial check to give be before
advancing the ponte h7 uh because it
guards the uh the h1 square and that's
very important here so king to d6 we
have h7 and he was in this position on
move 41 that uh alexis shiro resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here uh the thing is okay it seems
like you can capture the pawn but if you
capture the pawn then of course the
queen the uh queen to d8 check and the
rook on d1 uh just false or maybe you
don't even have to capture the rook you
can just deliver checkmate so that's not
gonna not gonna work and if you don't
capture the pawn if you play rook to g1
check now just king h2 and there is no
rook to h1 that's why the queen on a8 is
so important to guard the the h1 square
and you of course will resign here if
you didn't already resign after playing
a after arjun played h7 and move
on move 41. if you had this position in
a bar maybe against someone who already
had a few beers maybe then you might try
something like rook h1 queen captures
queen a queen captures an h7 check now
and then after the queen trade you know
you try to rush your pawn down the board
because it's a pass pawn and he might
have to give up the rook uh but that's
pretty much the only uh situation where
you where you try to even play this if
it's a gentleman's game you know no
beers involved then of course after age
seven you resign uh like shiro did here
uh so yeah uh that's the game i hope you
guys uh hope you guys enjoyed it it's
the uh first round of this wonderful
tournament um uh being played in sweden
so hopefully more great games will be
played but as arjun and shiro are
playing i have no doubt that we will be
seeing more great games uh and also a
lot of you have been saying that the
volume on my videos um
uh is low uh for uh i don't know for for
the past few videos so i've increased it
a little bit uh if it helps or if you
you know you you've even noticed um you
could also mention that just so i see
that uh you know there's a difference
uh so yeah once again i really hope you
guys enjoyed it very nicely played by
arjun as usual getting very very close
to that 2700 mark which will be which
will be huge
i would like to wish a very happy
birthday to benzona and i would like to
thank paul hindermund michael calbera uh
asher fine and joshua hadley for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh such as this
one and whatever else happens in the
chess world so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day